and you're gonna get you're gonna get a
sign
You are now live with Layer Eight Culture,
Tech Thursday.
Wow.
Yeah,
so he's going to give you a lot
of game, all right?
That's what I love about it.
We could throw this to our community right
here.
indeed indeed so thank you nathaniel for
inviting gloria thank you for having the
space the lab and just a brief
introduction who i am i'm donald tomlinson
i consider myself a technologist but also
a business person so my background
i've always been in technology i started
my professional career at ford motor
company setting up crm systems so we
transitioned from like an old siebel
system to microsoft dynamics there i was
doing basic i.t support and just had the
opportunity to be involved in that project
that huge migration got exposure to
consultants from hp
They came in,
affirmed my curiosity to understand
technology.
You know what you're doing,
you should be the specialist,
subject matter expert on this project.
I got lots of exposure to CRM systems
and how we use business applications and
technology together to drive business
value to move businesses forward.
Did that for a couple of years,
then ended up going to L. Three Harris,
which is Harris Corporation in time,
working with their CRM systems on the
sales side.
So within CRM,
you could do you have like field service,
which is your like maintenance plumbers.
The systems they use,
you have customer service,
which is like your customers looking at
cases,
documenting issues that they're having,
working with them.
And then you have sales,
where you look at how you go from
a pursuit to the sales pipeline towards
closing the opportunity and then
having it as one so that's your serum
for sales so that's what i did for
for l three harris for a couple years
ended up being a manager of that team
managing software developers uh got into
robotics processing automation which is
basically like automation prior to ai um
we had led a center of excellence at
l three harris where what we did was
We had this software called Blue Prism.
It was supposed to be great,
like low code, very easy to implement.
It wasn't.
And we worked with the accounting side of
the business as well as the legal side
of the business as well to see how
we can implement it.
And through that,
I learned a lot about how important
business process is when implementing
technology because I had to sit with the
accountants and say, okay,
this is
report that takes you five days to do
like what exactly are you doing and i
had to call them out like okay well
why are you copying this and putting this
over here like that's doesn't make sense i
had to explain all that and then i
had to translate all that they did into
something where the technology understood
it and we could take do shortcuts and
do all types of different things with
technology so i had to translate that in
real time and then relay that to my
software uh
engineers to then be able to create it.
So learned a lot through that process
about automation and how important it is
to have the right data,
the right context to really have it be
successful.
So after that,
I decided to exit the aerospace and
defense industry.
and goes to big tech.
So I'm now at Microsoft.
When I first joined Microsoft,
I was part of what's called ISD,
which is industry solutions delivery.
And at Microsoft,
we have a couple of different arms of
the company.
We have our product engineers who develop
the software, all that fun stuff.
They have a kind of a
go-to-market team that does high-level
marketing.
They'll do a lot of the beta testing
with specific customers,
go through the private preview,
the early release stages of the software
with them to get the bugs and things
like that.
They also work very closely with our
marketing department who just basically
makes the technology easy.
That's what we're known for at Microsoft.
We take very complex technologies and we
make them simple for everyone in the
world.
So my role was to basically take that
engineering product,
the marketing context,
but actual go-to-market solutions when it
came to delivering these solutions to
large corporations, like large companies.
hospitals, banks, you name it,
I had to build a solution for it
and it had to be scalable.
So you're talking not just a solution for
Bank of America,
but a solution for the banking industry
where we can actually sell that offering
as Microsoft,
package it up and have it make sense
so that
a salesperson could then take my offer and
they could say, okay, well,
I could sell this for one point five
million or more, ten million.
So I had a lot of experience.
I loved it because it was very
entrepreneurial.
It was basically like managing your own
business.
I had to create the offering,
had to do the marketing behind it,
had to do the actual assets, data sheets.
customer presentation, all that.
And then I got a chance to work
with like the best salespeople in the
world.
And they're just fun to work with because
they make selling easy.
So that was a really good role.
But that was focused a lot on business
applications.
And
I spoke with my mentor at Microsoft and
she was like, you know,
where you wanna go,
you wanna be able to understand the entire
product stack,
not just business applications,
but you wanna be able to understand
everything.
So she gave me the opportunity to work
with same go-to-market offerings,
But to bring those offerings to a platform
internally,
so I had to understand security,
had to understand cloud and AI,
had to understand databases.
It was a lot of different things,
just the breadth of the business.
I had to have a good understanding of
to be able to bring it into an
internal catalog.
So I was able to do that.
created agents when this is when ai's
first started kicking off so we created a
sales agent so that the sellers can go
to this agent and get an understanding of
the all the offerings and how that a
specific offering could apply to a
customer and this was uh probably two
years ago so after that
It is a lot, right?
So then after that,
decided to join the cloud and AI team
at Microsoft,
what was called unified support.
So we have a support arm of the
business where we sell,
we sell our product licenses.
Yep.
There's a lot of money here.
There's money everywhere at Microsoft.
But we sell our licenses for the product.
But then along with selling the licenses,
we sell support agreements as well.
So as the customer purchases licenses,
they'll purchase hours in a support
contract.
So they'll purchase at minimum,
you're talking like,
four hundred hours in a year.
We could blow that up to as much
as twelve hundred.
Exponential.
So we sell those support agreements
because we know that if the customer buys
the product and they have Microsoft on the
phone to support it,
they're going to be more successful.
They're going to spend more in their
cloud.
They're going to utilize the service even
more, which is good for us.
And then...
as part of that sales cycle we also
have internal professional services like
microsoft support engineers that can
actually be on site with the customer as
cloud solution architects to really drive
workshops to drive um accelerators or like
innovation ideation type of workshops
where we're not necessarily coding where
we're right behind the customer coding
with them and like helping them along
working with their IT team,
working with their business folks,
doing training, things like that.
So we find good ways to burn those
hours up, renew contracts.
What I do on the Microsoft side,
a lot of people say,
you work at Microsoft,
you must be a tech guy.
I'm like half and half.
I'm more of a business strategist.
So at Microsoft,
what I do is I make sure that
those unified agreements go to the right
customers.
I create propensity lists.
I create business models.
to say, hey,
we need to target these ten,
twenty accounts for this quarter.
And if we win those,
we can hit our budget that funds the
actual engineers that these people are
supporting.
So last year we had a one point
three billion dollar budget.
We're able to.
Yes, it was huge worldwide.
So we're actually able to exceed that.
And how you do that?
you have to be able to scale your
solutions so i take that principle of
business and technology and put it
together anytime we build tech not build
on technology the solution has to be
scalable it can't just be a hey i
built this this is cool it has to
be able i have to be able to
pass over nathaniel and he can use it
i have to be able to pass over
gloria and she can use it and that's
a real solution
So this idea of layer A culture started
up in about March.
And around that time, even at Microsoft,
we had some really,
really good investments in AI internally.
we have this product called GitHub
Copilot.
And it really like,
it was a product that I created, offering,
created go-to-market content on.
And we said, okay, well,
this product is really for developers
within organizations.
So we would sell it and say, hey,
if you have a development team,
use this product.
GitHub Copilot has AI assistance and these
developers can leverage AI when developing
code.
That was great.
In Microsoft, we saw that, hey,
as employees,
we have licenses to this product as well.
One of the guys that I work with,
he reported to my boss.
He posted something and said, hey,
we just released this beta version of
GitHub Copilot.
You should really use it.
And I was like, why not?
So I installed it, started using it.
And for my propensity list,
of these different accounts i take tons of
data across the company so i'm looking at
um our offering catalog i'm looking at the
actual customers the account how they use
our products what products they already
purchased the pipeline like what what
opportunities have already been sold what
were opportunities that have been lost i'm
getting an understanding of who that
customer is and matching up the right
recommendation of offering
And then making sure that it has high
propensity to close.
And I just hand that over to the
seller.
So that process alone would take at least
half a day.
At least half a day.
So it's going through Excel.
You know, like you mentioned,
we were like going through different Excel
tables, having to join different reports,
exports, all this crazy stuff.
I was able to...
take that process and create a program.
And it ran in seconds, like seconds.
I hit a button,
it ran a PowerShell script, it was done.
And that's when I was like, okay,
this is real.
And what I did was,
I'm naturally a leader.
And the way I lead is that I
lead by replicating myself across my team.
So if I'm able to do something real
cool and it's like, this is awesome,
I don't feel fulfilled.
I don't feel like it's completed until my
entire team can do that thing.
So I met with the team.
I brought them in.
I'm like, hey, guys,
this is cool technology.
We have access to it.
We need to start using it.
And I set up a hackathon internally.
And we had a offsite coming up in
Silicon Valley,
because we're a global team.
So we met in Silicon Valley,
had the hackathon there,
and I showed him how to set the
software up.
I basically let them say what their issues
were like what their problems they want to
solve for and just kind of guide them
along like okay use these prompts set it
up this way and they got results and
then I did I showed my VP and
she's like.
this is amazing like i need to like
i need to sit down with you donald
and we need to do this together and
it's just a snowball effect that happened
since there since then i ended up doing
a
on was like the last day of may
with uh business owner uh cameron barker
from fob flow he's up in palm bay
it's a marketing company and he said i'm
gonna do it twenty for twenty four hours
and five a.m on friday to five a.m
the next day we sat
And the cool concept was that I was
using GitHub Copilot.
It's an AI technology,
but I didn't want to be the expert.
I wanted to show that it's possible for
anyone to learn because that's the real
key about this.
You have to be able to learn and
you got to do it fast.
And there's a process to learning.
I went to Cloud Code,
got the subscription.
I've never used Cloud Code before.
I'm like a ChatGPT, GitHub Copilot guy.
So I've never used it before.
He's never used it before.
And I had my laptop, he had his.
And we went from the point of installing
it, setting it up,
by probably the eighth hour,
just going through the motions.
I did not write not one line of
code.
I did not put a prompt in.
I was just telling him what to do.
Like, hey, put this in.
And he's like, it's working.
Then by that eighth hour,
he was able to take a process of...
He did these... So in his organization,
he does like a sales call.
Then he does an onboarding call with his
customer.
And they do marketing in a way that
it's organic.
So he actually...
provides the customer,
which is a small business,
like the prompt,
like basically a script on what to say,
hold your camera up,
make sure it's organic.
And then they will go and edit the
video,
set up the whole marketing campaign for
them.
So that's the part you want to automate
the part of like giving the customer the
script and like how to hold your phone
and all these little things they had to
like write up just, you know, themselves.
I was able to not only automate that,
but we did what's called brand voice.
So he had a certain way how he
wanted it to sound and how you want
it to feel and the kind of style
that he wanted to present.
We were able to replicate that across all
the companies that he worked with.
So when he gave them a script,
it was it wasn't the cookie cutter chat
gbt it was like the way he wanted
to sound and he was just amazing like
this is perfect like he got it and
then after that we did um we just
did a bunch of different automations um
and then for me the moment they could
because that's us i knew this stuff would
happen okay and for me the moment that
really uh changed the game for me was
It was like four o'clock in the morning
and I'm falling asleep.
I'm on the laptop.
I'm like, man,
what do you have like that I could
work on?
Like,
give me something to work on for you.
He's like, hey, I got this website.
This client sent over,
but they don't have much information.
It's like they got a flyer.
They got a couple of pictures like they're
starting from the ground up.
I'm like, send it over.
I got it.
So he sent me literally two flyers and
the name of the name of the company.
I threw that thing in my process,
and my process is I create that brand
voice just based off the flyer,
based off the pictures, had a mock-up set,
created the website,
had it available online under forty
minutes.
That's crazy.
Yeah, and that blew my mind.
I was like, wow,
because I created websites since I was
like a teenager.
It was amazing to see what I was
able to do with that.
So, LayA culture is really about
bringing us as users,
making sure we're part of the building
process when it comes to technology.
Because with AI,
and this is happening already,
technology companies are going to push
down software.
It's going to be mediocre, to be honest.
It's going to be mediocre software because
the real...
real power is the expertise that the
industries bring to the software that's
what really pushes ai like no no
technology company is going to be able to
create a solution for legal unless a legal
person is involved you know no we can't
make solutions for medical unless there's
a medical expert actually telling us like
okay what is the right way to do
this so
With layer A culture,
I'll go into a little bit.
Within technology,
you have about seven layers of technology
that when it comes to technology,
it has to go through.
Your network, your transport,
your application layer.
These are just scientific principles of
technology.
My thesis is that I propose that eighth
layer, and that's that human layer.
That's me and you.
That's us.
Because when it comes to this AI,
we're part of it.
When you prompt
Your AI, that is code.
And Johnson Hahn, the CEO of NVIDIA,
he said himself, it's a brilliant quote.
He says,
English is the new coding language.
And it really is.
We have to be able to get our
language type and crypts so that the AI
can understand it.
And that's when it comes to the prompting,
being able to set context.
I have a funny story about context because
me as a technologist,
I just automatically know like, okay,
as an adult, you kind of know,
like you have to set context when you're
talking to folks.
And I have a teenage daughter and I
had to email her teacher
And I'm writing up the email.
She's in my office.
And she's like,
why are you saying all this stuff to
my teacher?
I'm like, your teacher doesn't know me.
I got to set context on why I'm
even sending this communication.
She's like, what?
So I was like, wow,
she doesn't know what context is.
And I thought I was like,
so who else doesn't know what context is?
And people are using this AI.
I'm like, you have to set context.
Because just like the teacher doesn't
understand where I'm from or who I am,
the AI has no idea who we are.
So we have to tell it like, hey,
I'm a business owner, or hey,
I need you to function as a marketing
expert,
or I need you to function as a
project manager,
because I need to make sure this project
that I'm about to propose is going to
be, the timing's going to be appropriate.
So I need you to be that expert.
So we need to set context,
and language is where that all starts.
So when it comes to layer culture,
it's really about
making sure that we're all aware of what's
going on with AI.
When this thing first started back in,
man, I don't even know,
it was about probably, I want to say,
is when I had my moment in technology.
And this thing came down from the
engineering
And they were coming to me personally
saying, Donville, what do we do?
Like, how do companies use this?
And I'm like,
you guys are building technology and not
thinking about how people are using it?
Like, no, that's their job.
I was like, okay.
So I broke down like a strategy of
how, you know,
we can go from basic implementing the
stuff to more advanced and it made sense.
But that was a learning lesson.
Like,
these people don't know what they're
doing.
They don't.
So we can't just say,
we're just gonna hand it all over to
them and put our faith in their hands.
We have to understand this.
We have to understand how it works,
especially as business, as executives.
We have to understand,
even if we're going to hire a consultant,
we got to understand what they're going to
do and how they're going to implement it
and make sure it's the right way and
be able to question them.
So we have to understand at least the
basics,
the foundations of how this stuff works.
And that's my main goal is to raise
AI fluency,
just at least to be able to understand
AI and how we're using it.
I got slides, but I like talking.
I like telling stories.
So hopefully this is beneficial as I'm
dropping a lot of these stories.
You're taking notes.
But I might use the slides to guide
us through.
So AI.
A lot of people say, okay, AI.
And they think of ChatGPT,
like that chat interface.
That alone was just an experiment.
That wasn't really...
It's supposed to happen, to be honest.
OpenAI is just a nonprofit.
They're messing around with these AI
models, and they created a chat interface,
and then that took off.
And they weren't thinking about how the
users would actually use it.
So when people started using ChatGPT,
they would go in and use it as
a search engine, right?
You'll go in.
It's a replacement for Google.
You'll ask the questions.
You'll be like, man,
it's giving me answers.
This is good.
It's like an expert.
It knows what it's talking about.
But guess what?
It doesn't.
So what happens is,
I'll break it down in very simple terms.
When it comes to AI and the chat
interface,
the only thing it's doing is making an
educated guess on what the next word is.
That's literally it.
It's saying,
Based on this word and this word combined,
the next word should be this.
And when it comes to images,
based on this pixel and this pixel
combined, this pixel is next.
And that's how I'm going to create an
image.
And it does it at just a really
fast pace.
So that's how it works,
just in simple terms.
And to understand what that next word is,
what the next pixel is,
it has to take training from us.
all that data we give out on google
on instagram anytime we're on the internet
we're giving data out for free and you
know i i have a little passion project
where i do i i'm gonna put it
out there i do think that it's going
to come to a point where our data
is intellectual property and we can
actually be beneficiaries of it.
I do see,
because it just doesn't make sense for
these companies make billions of dollars
off of your data,
your intellectual property.
I see it with musicians.
They're pushing it back now.
Will.i.am is somebody I follow a lot
because he's really big in technology and
AI.
He's got this whole concept of
why is the MP three that I made
equivalent to an MP three or a song
that AI makes the same?
It's the same thing.
And he's like,
there should be a proof of life.
if you get the MP three,
you can have a PLL file that says,
Hey, I actually put blood, sweat,
equity into making this,
and this should have more value.
So people are understanding like how
important that data is and like how it's,
how it's pushing the bottom line of these
corporations.
So that's the passion of mine.
Like I said, we're building AI fluency.
We got the proof points.
You guys know who I am.
Let's see here.
I went through how it actually works
already.
Yeah, this is the important part here.
So when it comes to, you might say,
man, Donovan, this AI,
I'm able to ask the questions and it's
giving me answers.
But it's giving you answers.
It's giving you the easiest answer it can.
When you ask an AI a question,
or just give it a prompt,
it's gotten that same question from
Hundreds of thousands,
probably millions of people.
It's not going to go out and cycle
its CPUs and think of a unique answer
for you.
It's going to give you a generic answer
that it gave everybody else.
So that's why you see,
you can tell a lot of things are
AI.
You're like, man, that's AI.
That's an AI answer.
Or you're like, man, that's an AI flyer.
That's real popular nowadays.
A lot of people are like, man,
these AI flyers are everywhere.
But you can, the important part is,
You have to give it data.
You have to give it context.
This slide is going to be,
I'll just skip to this one.
So.
There we go.
So it's all about the prompt, right?
This is the recipe.
And you got to have the prompt.
That's what you put in the chat interface.
You also have to have the data.
A lot of times users type the prompt
in, but guess what?
You could add an image to that prompt.
A lot of times what I'll do,
I love this tool right here.
Where is that?
I pin it on my computer.
The Windows Snippet Tool,
you could use that.
Take a screen grab of anything on your
screen.
And guess what?
It automatically puts it on your
clipboard.
You paste it right into ChatGPT.
It not only understands your words,
but it understands the picture.
It can scan it and then even mimic
some of the pictures.
If you want to create your own image,
use that as a reference,
you could do that.
So I use the snippet tool right here.
Yep.
And it's part of Windows.
Funny thing, so here's a funny story.
I actually teach on Fridays,
I volunteer to teach computer coding to
fifth through tenth graders.
at local school.
Because I just think it's important.
Like I said, it's a passion of mine.
We have to be able to learn in
a certain way quickly.
So even down to the fifth and tenth
graders, I had a kid,
we're doing this thing with coding,
block coding.
And he wanted to do something where it's
like kind of a Frogger game where cars
were passing by.
And I was like,
I think I know where it is.
But I was like, you know what?
Let's ask AI.
So I literally did a screen grab.
I popped it in ChatGPT.
I was like,
he wants to have cars flying by.
It gave me the code off of this
image.
It was like, we copied,
pasted the code in, and it worked.
And he was able to modify it.
It was done.
So that's how you're able to use your
flipping tool within Windows.
I think Macs have a similar tool as
well.
You can take screenshots.
Even if you're on your phone and using
ChatGPT,
Take a screenshot.
I do it all the time.
And clip it out and just paste it
into your chat.
It's going to give you much better
results.
So that's your data.
And even if, let's say,
you have a PDF.
You have a document you want to review.
That's still your data.
Let's say you have an email that you
want to provide that context.
copy, paste the email in.
Download the email,
drop that attachment in.
It's going to be able to read it.
And then last is the context of,
you know,
how you want the AI to respond.
Like, do you want it to
Have a professional tone.
You can even ask it to ask you
questions.
A lot of people don't know that.
You can say, hey,
this is what I'm trying to do,
but I don't think I have all the
information.
I want you to ask me questions before
you actually provide an answer.
And it'll go through and say, okay, well,
here's a follow-up question.
You know,
you'll be asking and have a conversation
back and forth with it.
I do that in my professional work because
we're very highly incentivized to use AHAI
at Microsoft.
So...
there's been times where i have a couple
different routes i can go with the
solution now i say yeah like okay well
what's what's the benefits of this versus
the versus that and it'll break it down
and like what data am i missing what
reports am i missing to make a better
decision they'll let me know so ask it
to ask you questions and it'll do that
so that's the recipe and this is all
level one so this is like
ChatGPT, anybody could do it.
Cloud code.
Get you a twenty twenty dollar a month
subscription.
And I've I've used ChatGPT twenty bucks a
month for like since twenty twenty three.
I just upgraded to the hundred dollar a
month because I was like,
I just wanted to be faster.
And trust me, it's it's worth it.
Yeah, it's faster.
And then the main thing about ChatGPT is
the image generation for me.
So a lot of people know that
With that twenty dollars a month plan,
you might do one image at a time.
You could do multiple images at a time.
Just off the twenty dollars a month plan,
you could do up to eight images.
You could ask it,
give me different samples.
Don't go back and forth.
Think of the AI as an intern.
You tell it, you give it the context,
you tell it what to do.
Don't let it just figure out on its
own.
No, I need three different mock-ups.
I need, you know,
give me two different solutions.
Give me the data and let me be
the one to add my point of view
and say, what is the final decision?
Yeah, don't let the,
that's why I think a lot of people
do,
they let the AI kind of be the
end all.
You are,
it's our point of view as humans to
really drive things forward.
So we're going to get all this data
from AI.
Trust me,
I've asked to do white papers and they'll
give me like a ten-page paper,
a dissertation on why, you know, this,
it'll have its own point of view.
But then it's for me to actually consume
that data and say, okay, you know,
based on my experience,
this is where I think we should go
with it.
So I gave you the recipe.
That's the prompt.
Here's another thing.
So like I explained a little bit,
the role, give your AI a role.
We understand business.
We understand project management,
sales managers.
What else?
Customer service manager, operations.
You want an accountant.
You want a business strategist.
You tell it what your intent is.
Give that AI a role.
Provide a clear task.
What is the outcome that I'm trying to
drive?
Always have that context.
And then this is key right here,
the format.
Man,
I can tell you something about this this
week.
I was using AI to basically create account
insights.
So when I hand over my recommendations to
sellers, I want a nice, tight...
a paragraph of data to say, hey,
based on what we know about this account,
this is why this offering should be
positioned.
And I went through probably five different
versions.
At first,
the AI gave me all these date points,
like this percentage,
and based on this propensity rating and
score, and I'm like,
the sellers don't want to see that.
So I had to say, all right,
give me,
give me some in plain language and
actually actually use this concept.
I said,
keep it at five hundred characters.
It's gotta be tight.
Like they gotta be able to look at
it, read it, understand it.
And boom, that's a good choice.
So I should use this.
And I did this at scale where it's
like,
we're talking about four hundred fifty
different accounts built out custom
account insights.
all formatted the way I wanted.
So that's the power of AI.
Go ahead.
I found myself too,
like it would give me data.
The data didn't make any sense.
And I would go back and say,
where'd you get this from?
Chad GPT would come back and go, oh,
you're right.
Yeah, like what?
Man.
yeah because it used to for a long
time i would um i think i uploaded
like my last military bio and it kept
saying you know twenty seven years and i
said well where'd you get twenty seven
from yeah wow oh i don't know sorry
glory oh my gosh see you might have
to get that hundred dollar plan because
slow
It's a little bit better.
And then that's the important thing about
data.
A lot of times,
some AIs give you the option to say,
go ahead and search on the web.
And some, I know Microsoft Copilot,
we give the option to say, hey,
only use the data that I give you.
So I could put in certain files.
certain PowerPoints and say,
this is all you got to work with.
Use this data, come up with the answer.
And it'll actually tell you, okay,
this source is from here, here, here,
within your actual data.
And then even like the AI that I
use at work, it actually refuses to,
like it won't present something,
especially because I do a lot with
sensitive data,
customer data and accounts and things like
that.
It actually will not provide like,
It won't make numbers up or say, hey,
let's say if we tell the customer to
spend three percent of their budget on
this,
it won't just make up value and say,
this is the benefit it's going to get
from spending that three percent.
It's going to say, no,
I need to make sure I validate.
So a lot of that is in the
instructions, in the context.
You could bake that into when you do
your prompt.
And then right, even right here.
So you mentioned that, constraints.
You can tell it like, don't,
don't admit legal fault.
You know, don't offer a refund.
Like, what,
this is what my AI should not do
at all.
You know, tell it that.
You know, treat it like an intern.
All right, let's see.
Oh, it's a good one.
Always reiterate.
When it comes to coding,
even from a technical standpoint,
you know, software developers,
they don't just go ahead and write code
and then just push it out to production.
They write code, we test,
we build some more, we get feedback,
we build some more.
So let's say, you know,
as a business owner,
you're putting together a proposal,
you know,
I'm going to put my proposal up together
as a PDF and catch a BT.
I'm going to send it over to Nathaniel.
Hey, check this out.
Check this proposal out.
You know,
I'm going to send it over to Gloria.
Check this proposal out.
What do you think about this?
And they might go through and say,
this is wrong.
That's wrong.
You changed this.
And I'm going to iterate.
You know, this is important.
I say to my students all the time,
reading is fundamental.
We need to read.
Like when this AI,
when we're chatting with it,
It's a conversation.
You see mine,
I got tons and tons going on here.
Got so much going on.
But you see mine's like,
it's a conversation back and forth with
this thing.
And then it's going to respond all that.
Guess what?
I should be reading all that.
I shouldn't just say, oh, this is great.
Copy paste.
Like, no, we got to read that.
We got to understand.
Okay, well,
This is good.
I said, where does it get this from?
How is it understanding the prompt that I
gave, the task that I gave it?
How's it, you know,
providing that answer back?
It's important we read this.
And then because we read,
we could then push back and get even
a better result because of that.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
Oh yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
Just what he would say in his marketing
on his page.
Nice, yeah.
Anybody have any questions?
Don't be shy.
I'm not shy at all.
It's thousands of things that I'm using.
Everything.
So I use it,
but I'm trying to figure out,
because you're not hitting the non-profit,
I'm trying to figure out how much chat
GPT Pro would be for the non-profit rate.
Right now,
I use whatever one is for twenty dollars.
Plus
This one is free.
I'm telling you.
Oh, yes.
I have a question.
What's your name?
David Jackson.
How are you?
Welcome.
I use AI to customize my resumes.
Yep.
Jim, ever since April last year.
Nice.
I've used it once,
maybe once or twice to craft a cover
letter on LinkedIn.
Yep.
That's good.
Yeah.
Even when it comes to like career,
I have a whole career chat where I'm,
I'm giving it like my, uh,
what we call,
we call them connects basically just,
we call them now the, uh,
Employee reviews, whatever that is.
We call them connects.
And even my connects,
like I'll put that into chat.
It understands.
I'll go back and forth with it,
like clean it up real nice.
And I'll even use that to drive further
career conversations,
like what my aspirations are,
update my resume,
like who I should be working with,
who should I be networking with,
all that stuff is in my chat.
But a cool thing is,
and as you can see,
mine is a mess,
but I do work closely with Nathaniel on
the Real Estate Deal Lab.
I developed a website.
A lot of technology he has.
Yeah, so before I do that,
so when working with Nathaniel,
I still wanted to use my GPT,
but I didn't want his stuff to get
all mixed up with my stuff.
Like, that would be horrible.
So you can actually set up what's called
a project.
So if you go up here,
there we go.
You can set up a project.
And that is basically a folder that keeps
the context all in a box.
So let's say I'm working with Nathaniel
and I work with Gloria on the lab.
I can set up separate folders and then
all of Nathaniel's content is in here.
And the cool thing, here's the kicker.
Remember I talked about data?
When you set that up, you have sources.
So when we work with Nathaniel,
Man, this man has, like,
just hundreds of files in a Google Drive.
And I was like,
give me all you got.
He's like, really?
Just give me access to everything.
And he said, I was like, man,
you got a lot of stuff.
So literally, I took everything he had.
I dropped it into the sources.
So all of his material.
linked it out to his Google Drive.
The cool thing is you can add sources
and you can actually just connect the
Google Drive with GPT.
You can connect Slack.
I think it only connects to one at
a time.
If you have multiple emails,
it does have issues,
but if you have one,
connect it up and it can read your
Gmail and your Google Drive.
It's legendary what he's talking about
right now.
I had a property like I said I
was doing one in Houston and I needed
to get all of my all of my
travel stuff right so this is like a
year two years of travel right I connected
it to my email and it searched it
in minutes it searched it had everything
in a spreadsheet all of my travel expenses
everything it was legendary I've never
seen that done before it's like ready to
give to a CPA yeah
do more for us.
So right now, we're doing the money.
Last year,
we did our first financial literacy,
financial literacy fair for kids.
But this year,
when I give out the sponsor package,
but we're starting a lot earlier.
I'm,
I'm having a hard time with changing the
team.
I want the cover of the video.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
So yeah, we have our separate folder.
We got all everything that Nathaniel has
far as fires content, even if you have,
um, what we built here, Mark.
Yeah.
We built out a marketing strategy,
added that to his sources so that when
we chat here,
The content that comes up,
like I'll show you the social media
content because we did a lot with social
media posts.
Like we were able to create content like
this.
Does that look like AI slop?
That's because we set the data.
We set context.
You know, we said like, hey,
we want to do something with...
This is not even... So here's the kicker.
That's not even one of the pictures.
I was like...
Somebody has shot me a deal and said,
hey, go check out this place.
It's not Obito.
Just imagine,
two and a half hours in Orlando area.
And he sent this to me.
I was like, dude,
I was on the way back.
I was like, how did you even know?
We're like,
we have to use this on his social.
Even with the palm,
what got me was the palm tree.
I was like, man,
that's a real palm tree.
But yeah, we...
We develop that and then we develop even
more content.
Let me see here.
It should be right.
Here we go.
So you see how consistent this is.
And that's because we built out what's
called a brand and voice.
So you could give ChatGPT your flyers,
your Facebook social media stuff.
Like, you know, if you have a website,
you can give your website a business card.
We've even done that where you take a
picture of a business card,
add that to it as a context and
say, hey,
build me a brand and voice document.
And I actually just did that with Gabe
Coleman last night.
And just off of his website,
we were able to build out this brand
and voice.
It's called a brand and voice markdown.
See, this is the problem.
That's simple.
Please build a brand and voice dot MD
for Gabe Coleman.
And we provide the website and it worked
for twenty minutes because it it went
through everything.
And I'm talking about when this when this
document was done.
this was like a yeah it's a doc
it's it is a document full document on
his personal brand taglines supporting
lines core promise like everything you
need even colors
even to the point of fonts,
like you as a brand,
you got to have a certain font.
So that's consistent.
People know that it's you, you know,
his license, everything,
the actual company name.
And that's just the beginning.
That's part one.
I think it's got about thirty different
sections.
but it will give you everything you need.
And basically, I sent this over to Gabe.
I was like,
add this to your ChatGPT so that now
that when you prompt it,
it's going to have full context of who
you are.
And then if you want to tweak it,
go back to this document.
This is the source.
So go back to this,
tweak it how you want it,
because that's going to be a
representation of who you are to the AI.
Another cool thing about this is,
guess what?
Now that you have this file,
You don't technically have to use ChatGPT.
You can take this file,
go to Cloud Code, drop it in.
Now Cloud Code knows who you are.
And you can ask that questions.
Gemini's out there.
You want to use Gemini?
Bring that file over.
Gemini's going to know without you trying
to figure out like, okay,
Gemini don't understand me.
I got to go chat back from Fort
Worth.
No,
use this file with whatever AI you want
to.
It's going to understand your business,
understand you and how you want it to
respond.
So very important to have that brand new
voice.
Um, it's called a brand voice.
Yeah.
Dot MD.
The important thing about a dot MD file.
At Microsoft,
we found out that actually we developed
that file at Microsoft.
AI can still read PDFs.
It could read Word documents.
It could read a lot of documents.
But the Markdown document is important
because it's all text-based.
It's clear text.
It's a very small file.
And it's easy for the AI to quickly
go through it.
If you give it a Markdown file versus
like a PDF or image,
Nine-day difference as far as how fast
it's going to be able to consume that
data and provide an answer.
So, that's why we say, you know,
use the mark.md file.
All right.
Last thing,
let's go into the real estate deal lab
because we,
Nathaniel and I did a lot of cool
stuff.
So, we built out the brand.
with all the,
he had years of data and we were
able to build out a full brand on
him and then take that brand file,
generate some mock-ups of what we thought
was important to have on a website.
So we had about three different options.
I was able to build those all out,
like as full demos.
So you can click around, use it.
And then we even leveraged the AI to
say, hey,
what is your recommendation and why?
So we didn't go with a cookie cutter
recommendation from the AI.
We actually took pieces of the best of
each mock-up.
Like we took a piece of the advisory
route.
We took a piece of the,
what was it?
I think having the videos,
like the video breakdowns.
All of the analysis, yeah.
I go straight to the YouTube.
Yeah, we took a piece of that.
And then along the journey of like
developing the website, iterating,
like I said, we build, we get feedback,
we build again.
So we did a couple of iterations after
the site was even live.
I was like, man, I was listening to,
I'll tell you a full story.
I was listening to Nathaniel.
He does a live every, what, Wednesday?
I was listening to him and I was
like, okay, this is cool stuff.
And I was like, man,
I'm a business process guy.
So as soon as he starts talking,
I'm like, I see the vision.
And I'm like, I think I asked you,
I was like,
so what is it that you actually do
when you break down these off-market
deals?
And he was trying to explain to it,
but he wasn't really getting to it.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm going to build a deal analyzer.
I'm going to try to build a copy
of Nathaniel.
So literally just taking...
a recording of that stream,
loading that into my AI.
I'm like,
what is this man talking about when he's
talking about bringing down these deals?
And it was like,
this is what he's doing.
He's looking at fix and flips versus
rental properties.
He's bringing in these numbers as far as
the purchase price,
how much the actual cost is going to
be, and then analyzing and saying, okay,
this is a good fit or not.
And when I showed Nathaniel, he was like,
He was like, this is it.
It was like, this is exactly it.
Any number that you take off from over
here, it shows whether the deal is solid.
Yep.
So we could say it's cash.
And I was just like, yeah.
So boom.
Like, strong deal.
You know?
That is crazy.
Yes.
free for everybody that goes off to the
website right what but it's like it's
helping people understand what i believe
is a real strong deal it's all off
the data yeah so i could i would
try and explain it to him but he
just took my live recording and put it
in there yeah so this is the custom
this is fully custom it's not like i
we linked out to any other third party
this is built
fully custom application.
And the cool thing is we can drive
value for the customer immediately.
So if someone already has a deal,
they go in here,
they put the numbers in.
I'm a process guy,
so you got to get the process.
They put the numbers in,
they get the basics, like, okay,
this is a good deal, this is cool,
but guess what?
The next step is I need to reach
out to Nathaniel.
And when they fill this form out,
we email them
We email them that report.
But then guess what?
Nathaniel has the breakdown of the actual
deal already.
So when Nathaniel calls them and he's
like, yeah, I understand your deal.
It's, you know,
you're trying to purchase a property at
two hundred sixty five K and this and
they're like, wait, what?
You know about my deal?
Like, yeah.
Look how informed Nathaniel is to that
customer.
He's locked.
He's ready to go.
Right.
I was like,
this could be translated to anybody's
business.
Exactly.
It's going to, you know,
line up everything and you get their
information.
Now you're able to reach out to them,
right?
Offer them offers.
And this is what they're trying to work
with me because I'm in the game still,
you know, I'm in the game.
But it's a very powerful tool.
Yes.
So thank you, Donald.
Yeah,
so that's what we're able to do with
AI.
And of course, like, as Nathaniel said,
this is scalable across many different
industries.
I've had roofing companies reach out.
They want something built like this,
where it's a quick,
they're actually quickly able to get a
quote, get it out to their customer.
Like, they were talking to me.
It's like days later from the time they
meet with the customer,
It'll take them days to get that proposal,
just a quote together.
And I'm like, we can automate all that.
We can make it so easy.
So a lot of companies have that need,
especially when it comes to like
consultative businesses where you want to
provide consultation,
but you need a lot of information from
the customer.
This could be very beneficial.
And I'll wrap up on this.
When it comes to websites,
But the past couple of decades, um,
SEO has been very important.
Search engine optimization,
how your website shows up in Google.
You want to have your website at the
top, right?
Using AI.
If you go to,
if you just copy this,
we'll just do a quick Google.
Uh, we'll just do it.
We'll do it the easy way.
Boom.
Not only is Nathaniel set up at the
top,
he's got like the whole page because the
way we're able to not only build his
website,
but then also optimize it with AI so
that you can go to any section of
the site.
Oh, I want to go to,
we'll say this lab, but I'm a contractor.
Oh, it's right here.
And I get straight to the contractor view
of the site.
Wow.
And it's all through AI.
The other thing about this is that we
have what's called AEO, AI optimization.
When you go to ChatGPT,
and let's say I go and say...
Okay.
I treat it as a Google search engine.
I say,
I want to find a foot doctor in
Palm Bay.
It's found several.
All right.
How does my age, why?
Here's the question we want to know.
Why is space close?
I can never say the same.
Why?
I'm not a medical person.
I've always messed with podiatry.
Why is Space Coast Podiatry LLC the first
option?
No.
Their website, they have good reviews,
but their website is optimized for AI to
read it.
A lot of people set their website up,
but guess what?
It's not optimized for AI to read it.
So, let me give you something else.
So, Nathaniel's doing these free e-books.
And I love you, Nathaniel.
I got to call you out.
He's doing these e-books.
And he's like, I got this e-book down.
It's a PDF.
And I'm like, okay.
We're giving away for free.
I'm like, the AI can't really read that.
Because we talked about PDFs versus text,
right?
I was like, send me the PDF.
We're going to make it an actual website.
So the PDF is actually all the data
is here.
That is the book.
i wrote a lot of yeah that's the
book on the site and ai is reading
all that now if you want to go
ahead and download the pdf we still
provide that you can down click the button
and actually get it but the digital format
you're able to read on your phone the
ai is able to read it and now
not only this this is like great it's
content but when it comes to real estate
deal analyze analysis
that Daniel's the expert that AI is
looking at.
And he could be cited as a source.
So, oh, yeah, this is.
I'm just, I'm still.
He's catching up to everything I'm doing
in there.
You know.
Yeah.
Yes.
but I know that it can really set
up like this.
Yup.
Yes.
Thank you.
So yeah, that's the whole site.
Well, thank you.
This has been great.
Thank you.
Oh yeah.
This is level.
There's so many levels.
This is level Lily.
This is level one of AI.
Just chatting with it.
When people say agents and, Oh,
I have this agent I'm setting up where
it can do work and run.
Or it can do things that are certain
scheduled time or have even multiple
agents.
So one thing I I've set up is
an organization.
You go to my website and get my
guides as well.
I have one right here.
Build your.
Yep.
Build your AI org.
So setting up multiple AIs,
you actually set up sub-agents.
So like you go in your chat,
you can say,
I want a team of agents.
to take on this task and I want
a marketing agent,
I want a project management agent,
I want a business management.
Like for me,
I even got like an executive assistant.
Like the time it takes for me at
Microsoft to say, okay,
I'm trying to run this program.
I'm gonna need to go hire these vendors
and make sure they know what they're doing
and be able to track them and all
that.
I'm building a team of AI agents to
say,
I got this project manager agent that's
going to go in,
just check the project timeline,
make sure everything's up to date,
reach out to all stakeholders,
checking on them, their tasks,
what they're doing.
That's all automated.
So we can run a team of agents
to get tasks done.
And we can tell the AI to do
that.
So I got that guide here.
In technology,
you'll hear a lot the term age AI
or frontier AI.
That is like the last level that we're
trying to hit.
And that is where these agents are running
autonomously across organizations,
just on their own, talking to each other,
getting full tasks done.
And we're still like pushing on getting
there.
So we, like Nathaniel said,
we're literally just scratching the
surface on how we're using this stuff.
I wrote it down because, you know,
what is that?
There's a Marvel movie, Jarvis.
Yeah.
The guy walks in, hey, Jarvis,
and Jarvis is doing all these projects and
stuff.
And, you know, that's what this is.
Oh, yeah.
And it really helps the solopreneur a lot
because there's a lot of,
there's a lot of new hats that you
have to wear.
I know when I first started this,
I was going to be an entrepreneur.
I realized as a chief that I was
spoiled.
I had an eye to spoil.
And then there was me.
Like the first computer issue,
like almost like broke down on the floor
and cried.
I went to grab the phone.
Nobody's on the other side.
It's not going to work.
Yeah.
So I think this is wonderful.
I appreciate you.
Definitely.
Thank you.
And given, you know, a lot of,
a lot of value that we were able
to kind of video,
maybe I'm going to sell it.
Yeah, we got the live stream too.
We're on live.
So we got everything.
We got everything.
He does technology live on Thursdays.
Yes, Tech Thursdays.
So I live stream.
So you definitely want to follow up for
that.
We'll link it into the lab.
Oh, yeah.
And second,
he didn't mention what a hackathon is.
Oh, yeah, I didn't.
I wanted to mention what a hackathon is
because we're going to start featuring
some here.
Oh, man, I'm going to love that.
Yeah, bring your laptop.
And actually, we do a lot.
We actually build live on what you're
working on.
I'm going to do it because y'all are
shocked.
I'm going to break it down.
yeah right so when he told me that
i was blown away because i've only done
eighteen hours of doing stuff he went
twenty four hours and i think he did
not think enough come on yeah not only
would you be creating websites but
literally they build they could build
companies
Yeah, and I'll break that down as well.
So, like, you say, okay, yeah,
it's like you say, like, oh, yeah,
you named the company Literary Culture,
but why culture?
And that is the part of community and
how we work together.
Like I said,
I've been in technology since I was a
kid.
I'm a little bit of a nerd, so...
Like back in the day,
and this is like late nineties,
early two thousands,
we have what's called land parties.
Right.
And I'm just give you all a little,
some nerd insights.
We would take our big old debt,
like the desktop computer is like this
big.
We would unplug that thing,
carry it to our friend's house.
Set it up next to our friends.
Have sleepovers, hang out.
And you would, like,
you would network the computers together
and, like, play games.
And that was, like, our thing.
We'll play games.
We'll download music.
Some people would do coding.
Like, it was, like, a vibe.
Like, it was a culture.
And... Exactly.
And a lot of times now, like,
you see people are getting into tech.
It's like...
they've lost that innocence of like,
we're doing this for fun, y'all.
I work at Microsoft.
I'm like, this is the dream.
Y'all stressed out for what?
This is my dream.
I'm like, I'm living the life.
I went to the Seattle campus.
I'm like,
Xbox is over here.
The CEO's office down there.
It's a campus.
I'm blown away because this is my dream.
So a lot of people get into it
and they're like, yeah,
I'm frustrated or I'm tired and this is
too much.
And I'm like, why are you here?
Because this is a culture.
This is not just like we're here to
make money or here to raise the stock
price.
When it comes to technology and how we
use it, it's a culture.
It's so important.
So
Yeah.
The way they learn and work through
different layers of the game and they so
good at it.
And it's like registering for them.
Right.
Those skills to.
And I think it only works as if
we do it together.
Like if we're in the same space and
I'm working on something and I can say,
and then what you working on?
And you'll be like, I'm working on this.
I'm like, oh, I'm inspired by that.
Let me add that into what I'm doing.
You know, that's, that's how, yeah,
that's how we work together.
So that's,
that's the concept of a hackathon.
Like you're taking problems and you're
tackling it as a team.
You're tackling, you know, as a group,
kind of figure it out what the best
solution is.
You're, you're showing, showcasing,
what your project is,
what your results are.
Yeah.
Get the music going, everything.
You know, that's a great time to go.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Because you have people that might work at
night.
If it's an open,
like an open house kind of thing.
If it's not like a pick time that
they have to be here,
like they can come, you know,
put your kids to bed and, you know,
come and be healthy.
Awesome.
Oh, sorry.
Can I come?
What's going to be?
You're back.
You get the invite.
Yeah,
but that's the important part about the...
That's the important part about the
twenty-four hours because I... Oh, man,
what's the name of the... Ah.
Something... Angela Duckworth.
She's an author.
I forgot the... Grit.
Yes.
Her book is gold.
If you don't have it, get it.
It's on Amazon.
It's a great book.
It talks about how people are super
talented, like, athletes...
Business people are very talented,
but guess what?
All that talent doesn't matter unless you
don't put the hours in.
And she talks about how these people not
only are very talented,
but they put the hours,
they put the effort in,
and that creates what's called grit.
And just imagine,
if I go in and I spend, what,
thirty minutes a day on this AI stuff,
how long is it going to take me
to get to twenty-four hours?
It's going to take a while.
I said, twenty-four hours,
I'm dedicating it to nothing but actually
coding,
actually understand learning this AI.
And the results speak for themselves.
If I was able to sit with a
guy that never uses stuff and he was
able to start developing and creating this
stuff.
Yeah.
But he was able to do it.
He was able to do it.
Yeah.
So like we have to put that time
in to be able to not only use
this stuff, but understand it as well.
So even for myself,
I'm in there every day.
I probably spend at least three hours a
day chatting with my AI for work.
And then I'm talking to actual human
beings too.
So this is great,
but you have to use it to be
able to understand it and just get better
at it.
we haven't decided it has to be a
friday saturday for me come on i got
church yeah yeah friday saturday yeah
we'll make it all right yeah i appreciate
you thank you thank you before you before
you go ahead i want to know
write down your businesses that you have
right and then when you when you i
want you all to check in number one
on facebook that you're in this event do
that right now yes go ahead on your
phone and check in and say how was
here this is how we get the information
out to the people that are in the
facebook algorithm to know that something
special just happened right we all took
some value oh yeah i'm gonna do something
and definitely check in and just say what
you thought of
what you learned here or what you learned
here.
Secondly, I definitely want, if you have,
everybody here has businesses,
put in the chat
I need a website that I can reach
out to.
You have the traffic school.
I need to make sure I have this
amount of customers.
type of marketing to all the high schools
or all the adult ads.
Because, hey,
I might need to create a course.
So whatever it is,
you don't want me to get started.
I'll do this.
I'm going to talk now.
But you have a lot of different
opportunities that you can throw in there.
and Donald and I and Gloria and everybody
that's in the membership,
we can just start chatting, right?
So you get your mind going.
So next time you come, right,
or you're ready to set up in a
consultation with, you know,
these young folks,
you have a clear path to start creating.
Okay.
Definitely.
Thank you.
So check in, number one, okay?
Check in and say, hey, I'm with you.
Take a picture or something.
Go over there and take a picture.
Can you put your slide back up to
the very beginning one,
like there are seven layers,
where are the eight?
Yes.
That's on the website.
Technology has seven layers,
where are the eight?
Yeah.
I want a picture with it.
All right.
And then also,
because I love talking about people when
they're doing this stuff,
this gentleman makes AI music.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about that.
Oh, man.
China style.
I want to hang out.
Oh, yeah.
When I looked at hers, I was like,
oh.
When I looked at hers.
Look at the layup down there.
I know I don't have to see it.
I can see it.
Hold on.
So here's another passion.
That's the important thing about if we're
actually ones building the stuff.
When it comes to coding,
when it comes to coding, like,
When I'm working, a lot of times,
I want to listen to music.
And I go... Suno, yeah, Suno, yep.
So, a lot of times, you know,
I'll bring this stuff up, and I'm like,
it'll be like some Asian kid,
and I'm like, I'm not inspired by that.
You know, like, this is not my style.
So I was like, you know what,
I'm going to build my own that is
the music that I like,
the kind of vibe that I want.
I got Larry Cole's radio, and actually...
Yeah.
And check this out.
So it actually live streams twenty four
seven.
And here's the cool thing.
Twenty four seven.
And it runs off of a cloud server.
And based on the time of day,
Eastern Standard Time,
it actually transitions the music,
the visual changes.
Like at nighttime,
it's the whole like nighttime thing.
Yeah.
It's like Afrofuturistic.
It's got a whole little vibe.
Yeah.
I was saying I teach at my son's
school.
Where's that?
Yeah, we do black polo.
at Eastman Christian Academy every Friday
from fifth grade to tenth grade,
teach them how to do block code.
Yes, during school.
It was actually like an actual class.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It's my curriculum, so, you know, I could,
yeah, I could teach it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I did with Microsoft like two years.
They are.
Exactly, yeah.
Summer school or something like that?
Yes, it was.
It was.
Even like the video animation portion of
it, that's AI as well.
I use this thing called Higgs field.
Yes.
So email is dthomason,
so d-t-o-m-l-i-n-t-o-m-l-i-n-s-o-n at
layeraculture.io.
Yep.
.io.
And then my phone number is three, two,
one, five, five, seven, three, four, one,
four.
And it's Donville, D-O-N-V-I-L-L-E.
Very good.
LarryCulture.io.
Alright, y'all.
Peace.